what was Al like I bet that was a good  combination for you that was fantastic I  mean Al is you know he's a legend he's  uh he's Al Pacino he's an amazing actor  certainly the you know the one thing I  didn't  really know about  Chino prior to to the shooting was that  he was certifiably insane  he likes to tell us tell jokes so yeah  he likes to tell jokes and he like to  tell me this one  specific joke over and over  and uh  I really didn't understand it yeah  didn't get the joke I didn't get the  joke yeah and he thought it was your  problem that you didn't get the joke  absolutely yeah yeah what do you  remember the joke yeah he lean over and  he'd go John  skeleton  goes into a bar  orders a beer  [Music]  and a mop